el ejecutivo brasileño redobla esfuerzos
para aumentar la vacunación en el país
lo hace mientras el gobierno da un golpe
de timón a su política contra la
pandemia y mientras la emergencia se
agudiza día tras día en la nación con
estos cuatro actos
estamos pidiendo 100 millones de dosis
de facer según lo programado transmisión
en abril 25 millones en mayo 10 millones
en junio 10 millones en julio 30
millones en agosto y 46 millones en
septiembre 46
septiembre el número total de vacunas
contratadas por el ministerio de salud
son 562 millones de dosis para el año
a pesar de ser uno de los países más
afectados la vacunación en brasil
comenzó apenas a mediados de enero y ha
avanzado lentamente en medio de una
feroz tercera ola de casos el presidente
de jair bolsonaro cambió su retórica
sobre la vacunación y admitió que es
fundamental para superar la pandemia en
los últimos días el mandatario también
comenzó a utilizar mascarilla y anunció
que reemplazará al muy desprestigiado
ministro
salud eduardo para suelo el tercero
durante su mandato
el presidente busca reorganizar el
ministerio
y 4 y eso no fue hasta que eso sea
definitivo la vida continúa de manera
habitual no estoy enfermo no he pedido
irme hasta allí se prevé que su
reemplazo el cardiólogo marcelo quiroga
hace al mando de la cartera en los
próximos días lo hace en un momento
crítico el país epicentro de la pandemia
en la región y de nuevas variantes del
virus ha superado por primera vez las 2
mil 800 muertes diarias por kobe 19 y
suma más de 281 mil decesos y 11,6
millones de contagios